je propose de terminer ses missions avec
un sujet heureusement plus léger en 2024
ce seront les jeux olympiques à paris et
jusqu'à présent il y a figurez-vous 28
disciplines sportives qui sont prévues
pour les jeux olympiques qui sont
enregistrées il pourrait en avoir quatre
de plus en 2024 c'est le comité
international olympique qui va devoir
décider ça à partir de la proposition du
comité olympique français
les quatre seraient l'escaladent le surf
le skateboard et le breakdance figurez
vous alors comme c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour moi parce que c'est mon
activité préférée du week-end mais comme
ce sujet a quand même un grand enjeu
on a demandé les lumières du meilleur
spécialiste qui est le patron du service
des sports du figaro la présence du surf
de d'escaladé et du skate demandant la
liste des sports additionnel pour parler
de 1024 est très logique car c'est des
sports qui sont déjà en démonstration du
côté de tokyo des jeux de tokyo en 2020
en revanche effectivement la grande
surprise c'est laury dance
qu'est ce qu'on peut lui reprocher à ce
break dance 2 pas forcément être un vrai
sport il ya plein de plein de
disciplines qui attendait pour intégrer
ces jo le billard le squash qui n'ont
pas été retenus qui effectivement sont
aujourd'hui excepté excessivement déçus
voire en colère
l'atout du break dance et quoi c'est
effectivement d'être assez proche d'un
univers qui correspond bien aux jo de
paris 2024 et notamment la seine saint
denis car effectivement l'un des
objectifs l'une des des contraintes qui
avait été imposé par le par le cio pour
ces sports additionnel c'était que on ne
crée pas de d'infrastructures
supplémentaires et que ces deux
nouvelles disciplines colle finalement
au jeu de paris 2024 et aux aspirations
du seuil haut depuis toujours le cio
intègre de nouveaux sports des petits
sports qui sont pas très connus et tout
ça pourquoi pour rajeunir son image pour
aller un peu plus loin pour faire du
jeunisme presque envie d'y rester et
c'est la limite effectivement de ce
break dance c'est de se retrouver
finalement avec des jeux qui pourraient
perdre leur âme
alors nous avons hâte d'avoir votre
point de vue sur ce sujet je vais vous
donner celui des des internautes du
figaro puisque c'était la question
d'hier sur le figaro.fr faut-il
introduire le break dance aux jeux
olympiques de paris en 2024
c'est plutôt non pour être tout à fait
honnête puisque 87% des près de trente
mille votants
ils sont est favorable bertrand
en perrier ceci chaleur de vous amuser
alors et vous est ce que pour reprendre
les arguments de martin couturier c'est
un c'est un peu du jeunisme 2 c'est
aussi un clin d'oeil à la banlieue parce
que ça va se passer en seine saint denis
il ya plusieurs choses
le break dance est d'abord une contre
culture c'est une culture rebelles
culture de gang qui s'opposent entre eux
et qu'ils sont plutôt anti sociaux à
l'origine et donc il ya aussi l'idée
d'une récupération c'est que on
institutionnalise cette danse qui est
plutôt rétive à l'embrigadement dans des
codes dans des règles d'ailleurs la
question des critères de jugement se
posera inévitablement
reste qu' il ya déjà des compétitions de
break et là où c'est intéressant c'est
que ces compétition de breakdance sont
sponsorisées aujourd'hui par des marques
d'alcool fort notamment
et donc c'est peut-être pas
inintéressant non plus que l'on fasse
rentrer cette culture urbaine dans le
cadre de jeux olympiques officielle pour
permettre aussi de les populariser de
les passer à la télévision et de les
cadrer un peu à la presse que ça perd
son âme parce que ce serait une culture
par hypothèse rebelles c'est aussi
probablement un peu le cas est-ce que
c'est lié au fait que c'est en seine
saint denis oui peut-être est-ce que
c'est une raison pour bourde pour bouder
son plaisir
probablement non moi je suis plutôt
favorable c'est une reconnaissance d'un
art après tout il ya plein de
disciplines olympiques qui relève
je pense au ski de bosses où il ya une
notion esthétique nécessairement
subjective
même dans le patinage il ya aussi ça bah
il c'est une autre épreuve esthétique
technique aussi et donc ça ne me
choquerait pas que le breakdance se
fasse son entrée aux jeux olympiques
alors les points de vue de nos
internautes ça c'est partager
jean-michel nous dit le breakdance tel
qu'il est pratiqué est très sportif
alors que pat cru nous dit et pourquoi
pas le tango et les mots croisés et
puisent aux veaux qui a peut-être été
plus tard la pensée en tête
on va avoir plein de médailles pas bête
point d'exclamation adrien matou mais en
fait c'est un débat qui est passionnant
qui au vert parce c'est pour ça qu'on
l'a ce soir c'est qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un sport qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
sport olympique
parce que c'est avec le breakdance on a
une espèce de réticences inconsciente
quand on voit le bras gagnent leur
entrée aux jo alors peut-être pas pour
bertrand dr
mais émaillant ses parents ne sait pas
comment la formaliser parce qu'on se dit
c'est pas un sport c'est une danse etc
mais il ya déjà des sports qui sont sur
notre ce qui est d'ailleurs à créer
parle de problèmes parce que la
corruption des juges c'est beaucoup plus
facile que la corruption du chronomètre
voilà par exemple le patinage ou même la
gymnastique 1 mais c'est assez
intéressant quand même parce que c'est
vrai qu'il ya cette volonté un petit peu
artificielle quand même de de casser
l'image des jo mais il faut garder à
l'esprit qu'il ya un nombre limité
d'épreuves quand même alors il ya plus
un nombre limité de sport parce que la
limite de 28 spa on va être va sauter
mais il ya un nombre limité d'épreuves
et ce serait quand même à mon avis
dommage même si j'y arrive pas le
formaliser de manière explicite de de
virer des sports peut-être plus
classique pour faire de la place au
breakdance qui est quand même un coup de
com - alors plusieurs choses d'abord moi
je pense que les jeux olympiques
l'objectif des jeux olympiques quand on
les accueille dans un pays c'est aussi
pouvoir faire rayonner nos valeurs notre
culture notre patrimoine et
personnellement j'aurais préféré par
exemple qu'on mette la pétanque bon
choix personnel mais au delà tout ça je
pense qu'il faut aussi se poser la
question de la façon dont les jeux
olympiques vont se passer dans notre
pays les jeux olympiques depuis
plusieurs années ne respecte plus
l'article 50 de la charte des os des
jeux olympiques qui impose la neutralité
politique philosophique et religieuse
sur les stades
on le voit notamment avec le port du
voile d'un certain nombre d'athlètes de
sportive est la question qui est ami et
qui est admis aux jeux olympiques depuis
plusieurs sessions donc la vraie
question elle se pose à mon avis là c
est ce que la france va accepter qu'on
continue à transgresser cette charte est
ce qu'on va continuer à accueillir dans
sur notre territoire des pays qui
appliquent une une transgression aussi
de l'égalité femmes hommes dans leur
propre pays je pense par exemple à
l'iran et à l'arabie saoudite sont des
pays qui pratiquent un appareil sexiste
alors qu' il y a quelques années lorsque
l'afrique du sud pratiquer l'apartheid
un apartheid raciste on les avait
exclues
donc moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui le rôle
de la france ce serait d'avoir un rôle
fort sur le cio pour faire en sorte que
ces pays comme l'afrique du sud en son
temps ne soit pas admis à participer aux
épreuves tant qu'il ne se permettent pas
aux normes en terme d'égalité femmes
hommes et maintenant voici le moment
tant attendu de cette émission nous
allons enfin savoir ce que guillaume
bernard pense du
jeune il a écouté figurez vous que je ne
me doutais absolument pas qu'un tel
sujet puisse donner lieu à des arguments
aussi un terrain effectivement aussi
intéressant parce que très franchement
moi ma position elle était tout
simplement celle ci je me moque
complètement de savoir quelles sont les
épreuves qui sont aux jeux olympiques
vous n'êtes pas bon et et j'avais plutôt
le sentiment au départ que tout
simplement plus vous élargissez le
nombre d'épreuves ou en tout cas de
sports représentait plus vous êtes
susceptibles d'avoir de téléspectateurs
et plus vous pouvez faire du business
moi il me semble qu'il ya peut-être ça
qui est derrière et que je dirais l'acte
gratuit la beauté du geste de la lutte
gréco romaine à l'époque antique à un
tout petit peu disparu voila voila mon
avis extrêmement érudit sur la question
est-ce que c'était le dernier mot peut
ajouter quelque chose alors on a tout la
grèce antique et le breakdance s'agit a
cédé la ja qu'au figaro qu'on peut avoir
cette ce télescopage des mondes sevani
fille et maintenant nous pouvons partir
en week-end sereinement après un tel
succès merci beaucoup à tous de nous
avoir suivis et à lundi pour une
prochaine émission de points du très bon
week-end
[Musique]